vous êtes une famille nombreuse avec
combien d'enfants alors Olivier et souk
davod vous êtes les parents d'une vraie
tribu vous avez 9 enfants exact la 9
enfants Mathieu Olivia Théo Chloé Elsa
Alicia Rudy Nolan et jadou vous faites
l'appel tous les matins
maintenant avant
il y en a qui sont partis on fait moins
la peine un feu de quoi dans la vie moi
je suis j'ai mon entreprise je suis dans
le bâtiment je fais ce qui est peinture
et sol et vous moi je suis femme au
foyer
vous êtes vraiment plus débordé que nous
tous c'est normal mais plus que votre
mari
vous avez voulu avoir autant d'enfants 9
enfants comment ça s'est passé
comment ça s'est passé alors
c'est vraiment un choix ou bien alors
moi j'ai toujours voulu avoir beaucoup
d'enfants donc moi je suis alors après
je sais pas si ça vient de ça je suis
l'adage j'ai fait beaucoup de foyer donc
j'ai vécu avec plein de camarades et
j'ai trouvé que c'était ma famille et
j'ai toujours dit que plus tard que je
voulais trouver une femme qui parce
qu'il faut trouver la femme aussi qui
bien sûr dit dès le premier rendez-vous
pas le premier rendez-vous parce que
j'ai mis longtemps à l'avoir souk
c'était toujours mon rêve de asiatique
déjà alors moi dans la rue dans la rue
attention attention
j'avais un fantôme de sortir avec une
asiatique et donc je suis parti avec mon
cousin essayer de draguer trouver une
asiatique et j'ai trouvé
c'est vrai on avait jamais quoi 14 ans
vous avez flashé tout de suite vous
l'avez vu ah moi j'ai flashé c'était pas
genre pour faire ma vie avec au début ah
ouais
ce soir
au début c'était je pensais plus à autre
chose moi voilà
il vous abordez dans la rue
mais bon je t'ai pas trop intéressé
alors je suis montée chez ma copine pour
qu'il me qui me les laisse tranquille et
je suis resté longtemps et j'ai vu que
qu'il était encore en bas mais j'étais
obligé d'aller chez moi j'avais pas le
choix après je suis redescendu ben ils
m'ont accosté et puis après j'ai parce
qu'on était
vous avez succombé
et donc ensuite quand est-ce que vous
l'aviez dit pour la première fois que
vous vouliez avoir une très grande
famille je pense que à 16 17 ans
commence à discuter que mais c'était on
en parlait comme ça je dis ouais plus
tard je voudrais une grande famille
beaucoup d'enfants connus à quel âge on
avait 14 ans
[Musique]
ça fait presque 33 ans qu'on est
ensemble
et très vite
on voulait déjà on en parler déjà on en
parlait déjà
incroyable on parlait déjà
dit c'est incroyable
dormir c'est là où
vous avez eu donc 9 enfants ils ont ils
ont quel âge aujourd'hui de 28 ans à 6
ans
on a voulu arrêter au 8e d'accord on est
voulu arrêter avec Nolan et après on se
dit 4 gars quatre filles franchement
c'est merveilleux et après on a eu du
mal à voir jade moi je voulais plus elle
voulait et on a réessayé le jour que
j'ai dit que j'arrêtais ça a marché
comme par hasard
et nous avons notre petite dernière jade
avec aucun regret bien sûr et 9 enfants
ça doit être une organisation de fou on
va juste voir regardez comment vous
organisez pour les courses quand on est
une famille nombreuse c'est un peu
compliqué
la nourriture c'est 75% des factures
c'est le plus gros budget le plus gros
budget
pour vous dire que ça c'est un repas
c'est un repas c'est énorme c'est pour
ça qu'on fait vraiment attention à tout
ce qu'on achète et tout parce que on se
rend pas compte que c'est multiplié par
7 8 9 10 c'est vraiment on prend
vraiment en grosse quantité vraiment les
gens se rendent pas compte parce qu'en
fin de compte une boîte de 10 steaks
hachés nous c'est un repas on se fait
1,2 repas c'est vraiment incroyable
c'est la boîte de 24 œufs c'est
l'omelette et on divise déjà la boîte en
deux pour un repas
alors c'est vrai que quand on fait les
courses quand on a une famille nombreuse
vous avez 9 enfants et ils sont tous à
la maison puis maintenant alors il nous
en reste que quatre maintenant ça va
comment on fait les courses quand on est
une famille nombreuse comment on fait
ben on va au magasin et
le plus gros budget c'est nous quand il
y avait plusieurs enfants quand il y
avait 7 enfants on mettait jusqu'à 1200
euros de courses par mois
c'est énorme en plus les parents parce
que on dit les enfants mais il y a les
parents aussi qui mangent exactement
[Rires]
le le truc fou de des familles
nombreuses c'est ah ouais c'est au
panier de course est-ce qu'il a augmenté
parce que là maintenant vous avez encore
quatre enfants c'est ce que c'est c'est
parce que vous vous sentez vraiment une
augmentation alors franchement on le
ressent maintenant la des ces jours-là
qui viennent on le ressent on était à
700 entre 700 et 800 maintenant on monte
presque jusqu'à 1000 euros parce que ne
serait-ce 200 euros c'est énorme pour
nous budget c'est les gens seront pas
que comment c'est c'est horrible c'est
vraiment tout autrement et puis il y a
pas que la bouffe
j'ai la voiture j'ai le camion
d'entreprise il faut que ça ça marche il
faut et tout ça et c'est c'est vraiment
vous sentez vous sentez aujourd'hui que
vraiment vous avez une pression
supplémentaire moi oui vraiment en tant
que chef de famille papa ouais mais
pourquoi vous dites tous les jours tous
les jours je stresse parce que moi si
demain j'ai pas de chantier j'ai pas de
travail je peux pas nourrir mes enfants
ma femme donc c'est quelque chose qui me
hante un petit peu parce que une
entreprise pour la faire marcher puis
voilà mais plus tous les augmentations
qu'il y a en ce moment c'est encore pire
de c'est de pire en pire donc voilà donc
ouais je stresse vraiment tout le temps
tous les mois je pense à l'autre moi en
espérant que je vais avoir du tout ce
que vous faites vraiment des calculs
pour voir comment vous pouvez oui ben
moi c'est selon mes chantiers mais par
mois par mois c'est quand vous étiez
voilà là vous avez encore quatre enfants
à charge vous aidez un petit peu les
autres quand même aussi comment pas du
tout vous aider un petit peu les autres
enfants ou pas les cinq autres ou pas du
tout ils sont complètement autonomes
maintenant les grands sont autonome
c'est peut-être plus eux qui nous aident
que ouais c'est vrai parce que on a on a
vraiment une fumig soudée il le savent
que on a des difficultés des fois et nos
enfants nous le rendent bien sur tous
les grands
surtout les grands ils nous rendent de
super bien et on peut être que faire de
nos enfants sincèrement alors c'est vrai
que votre panier de course a augmenté
vous avez dit l'ambiance chez vous
est-ce que voilà vous aviez beaucoup de
disputes clans de trucs comme ça alors
des clans peut-être pas mais oui des
disputes bien sûr ça arrive entre nous
entre nos enfants heureusement ça nous
remet en question puis c'est des fois
sur l'aurait encore plus fort on a le
droit de pas tous être d'accord on a
chacun notre vie on a chacun notre
situation et on peut pas être d'accord
sur tout ça nous arrive parfois de faire
des réunions de famille des fois ouais
pour mettre tous les chevaux
alors on a une pilote qui nous pilote un
peu alors il y a été eau vous avez quel
âge j'ai 27 ans 27 ans c'est pas l'aîné
exactement et et vous tu es où j'ai 25
ans je suis le troisième 25 ans vous
venez vous n'hésitez plus à la maison
aussi non c'est ça les deux vous êtes
partis
sur les réseaux sociaux maintenant suite
à l'émission sur TF1 et ouais j'aide
beaucoup mes parents par rapport à ça
parce que j'ai de la chance d'avoir un
meilleur revenu depuis et je les aide
beaucoup on a toujours été éduqué dans
la solidarité CD donc c'est hyper
important pour moi et je pense beaucoup
à eux tout le temps
vous êtes marié
comme tous les frères et sœurs apprendre
à voir autant non déjà j'en ai eu un je
suis encore traumatisé décontractions
vous êtes encore plus admiratif de votre
maman je la comprends et quand on
devient parents mon frère aussi et sa
petite fille a pas longtemps on comprend
plus les inquiétudes le stress qu'ils
avaient au début on était là les parents
ils sont relous toujours derrière nous
etc mais maintenant qu'on a des enfants
on comprend tout moi j'ai mon fils
maintenant et totalement 25 ans vous
avez déjà un enfant
une petite fille de 7 mois là et vous
votre femme vous lui dites quoi vous
dites vous avez envie d'avoir plein
d'enfants comme vos parents ou pas du
tout moi j'aimerais bien une deux trois
enfants mais mais pas plus parce que non
c'est trop c'est trop parce que quand on
voit là quand on va l'organisation qu'il
faut bah à la maison même financièrement
déjà j'ai un enfant je trouve que c'est
cher donc neuf ouais c'est il faut
assumer quoi il était très très
courageux et sans on sera toujours
reconnaissant envers eux ça c'est sûr
alors c'est vrai pas c'est une galère
chacun mange où il peut regarder
[Musique]
c'est pas manger avec les autres dans le
salon
vous mangez soit dans le salon ou dans
la cuisine franchement bon ça nous
dérange pas
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'on parle c'est vrai
du panier moyen actuellement pour une
famille vous ça devait être un truc de
fou comment vous faisiez aussi pour les
factures tout ça
avant je faisais beaucoup d'intérim donc
on gère un petit peu mieux parce que on
avait quand même plus d'aide avant avant
faut dire qu'on avait plus d'aide on
avait quand même
on payait pas de trop de loyer on avait
voilà on avait quand même beaucoup
d'aide maintenant qu'on gagne un peu
notre salaire on gagne un peu notre vie
un peu plus ben on a pu d'APL on a plus
d'aide donc on payait exactement comme
tout le monde donc je travaille encore
plus dur parce qu'il faut savoir je
travaille tous les jours plus le
week-end donc vous travaillez vous
travaillez quoi tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jours dès que je suis
obligé alors je peux m'arrêter c'est moi
le patron je préfère comme je veux sur
mes mots vous pouvez mais je peux pas je
peux pas me permettre parce qu'il y a
des mois je peux gagner des 1000 l'autre
3000 l'autre 4000 mais si le mois que je
gagne 2000 il faut bien que je compense
voilà parce que on a beaucoup de
factures à payer on se rend pas compte
mais c'est
le prix du loyer coquement te
l'électricité le gaz c'est un truc de
fou ça nous rend fou ça nous rend ce que
vous et j'ai même peur pour l'avenir
même les sens les sens faut pour voir ce
que je suis dans l'ESS vous le referiez
aujourd'hui avoir 9 enfants ou bien oui
oui vous dites pas que c'est trop
difficile aujourd'hui avec franchement
peut-être si je sais que la vie elle
aurait été comme ça maintenant j'aurais
peut-être pas fait autant d'enfants
aujourd'hui j'aurais pas fait autant
d'envoyer parce que il faut voir
l'avenir pour eux après c'est eux qui
vont venir après un c'est pas nous hein
nous on nous on va subir mais eux
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont être plus tard nos
enfants nos petits-enfants avec tout ce
qui se passe maintenant pour moi c'est
mais j'ai jamais regretté mais c'est
vrai que si je savais que la vie elle
était comme ça maintenant je pense pas
que j'en avais autant
les enfants justement vous êtes parti à
ces jeunes finalement pour construire
votre vie de la de la maison est-ce que
c'était une volonté de dire ouais on va
construire notre famille parce que avec
toute cette famille nombreuse on s'en
sort pas c'est compliqué etc non pas de
fuir mais de dire ouh là là ça va
l'agitation va aller se calmer ailleurs
un peu assez jeune moi personnellement
je suis partie à 23 ans donc ça va je
trouve je sais que j'avais des copines
qui voulaient vite partir de chez eux
moi c'était pas le cas j'aimais bien ce
cocon famille et tous tous mes frères et
soeurs on en a déjà discuté quand on est
parti ça fait comme un choc parce que du
jour au lendemain on se retrouve à la
maison il y a pas de bruit on va aller
de se faire réveiller par les petits
frères et soeurs en fait le calme total
limite ça fait peur donc maintenant on a
pas du tout fui parce qu'on en pouvait
plus parce que quasiment tous les jours
j'ai 27 ans aujourd'hui je suis
quasiment tous les jours chez mes
parents avec mes frères et soeurs tous
les jours parce que j'arrive pas à m'en
séparer on est très très famille on fait
du foot ensemble on fait vraiment tout
ensemble
moi je partais un peu un petit peu plus
tôt parce que bah je suis quelqu'un qui
aime bien avoir mon intimité et c'est
vrai qu'à cap dans une chambre c'est
compliqué mais après j'ai vécu des très
bons moments ça sera des de très bons
souvenirs honnêtement
c'est j'ai vécu des choses que quelqu'un
qui est tout seul ou même qu'avec un
frère il a pas vécu quoi donc c'est
incroyable mais je suis quelqu'un qui
est parti assez tôt parce que j'ai
besoin de cette intimité vous êtes
proche de tout offrir oui
alors il y a un truc qui rend fou tout
le monde c'est les chaussettes toute
seule imaginez la tanasse qu'on venait
11 à la maison
un paquet de chaussettes perdues il y en
avait tellement que moi tout seul je
pourrais pas tout faire tout seul je
leur ai mis tout sur la table et qui
puisse m'aider à l'étrier
je peux m'en sortir toute seule hein
allez s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
horrible je déteste c'est drôle mais
tout ce qui est rouge on le met là c'est
par couleur on trie comme ça on verra
mieux
une famille nombreuse c'est plus
d'enfants plus de d'amour plus de bisous
mais plus aussi des chaussettes perdues
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que grâce à la popularité des
missions est-ce que du coup vous avez
des entreprises que vous propose des
partenariats qui vous aident pour le
l'alimentation etc ou pas l'alimentation
alors nous depuis qu'on a fait
nombreux c'est vrai qu'on a des
partenariats alors on profite
franchement je vous dis je le cache pas
on peut avoir des parcs d'attraction
pour les enfants des hôtels des des
petits séjours que nous on a pu déjà
qu'on pourra pas se payer et que on n'a
plus jamais faire en temps en tant que
parents et j'aime donc ouais on saute
sur l'occasion et tout ce qu'on nous
propose je le prends de je prends tout
de suite sans hésiter et voilà oui on
vous expliquer que vos enfants vous êtes
dès qu'ils peuvent financièrement ça
veut dire concrètement et il vous donne
une somme d'argent de temps en temps où
ils font un plein de courses
pas trop d'argent mais ils nous achète
des cadeaux ils peuvent nous acheter ils
savent si on a besoin d'un four il nous
achète un fournisseur si on a besoin
d'une machine à laver les achète machine
à laver vous voyez ce que dire mais ça
vient de même si c'est c'est pas nous
jamais en tant que parents on leur a
demandé quelque chose jamais c'est ça
qui est beau qu'en fait c'est nous qui
doit dans mon venir à leur à leurs
besoins mais comme nous maintenant on
vit dans une société qui est un peu très
dure et compliquée les enfants le savent
et comme il y en a qui s'en sortent un
petit peu mieux et ils rentrent bien et
parce qu'il faut pas Olivia comme je
prends exemple Olivia elle fait pas que
nous que aux parents alpha frère et sœur
elle fait tout le monde donc c'est
vraiment notre force de la famille c'est
vraiment et quand moi je peux bien sûr
moi mes enfants je sais que quoi qu'il
arrive je serai toujours là pour mes
enfants alors peu importe ce que je dois
faire il y a aussi des des relous qui
vous critiquent sur les réseaux
c'est ce que c'est mes amis parce qu'il
y en a qui disent que vous profitez de
la CAF tout ça en ce moment ah ouais
c'est vrai ça me fait on a eu de la
chance de partir en vacances à la
Réunion on est revenu ils ont dit que
c'était défoncer sur les réseaux
comme quoi on profite de la CAF on a un
clan de la CAF
des trucs
vous savez maintenant ils font tellement
rire mais franchement ça me fait
vraiment rire c'est minable est-ce que
ça vous touche vous parce que
franchement non et en plus franchement
par rapport à la communauté qu'on a
c'est vraiment une infime partie
maintenant qu'on va forcément
d'arguments c'est les stéréotypes des
familles nombreuses
nous on sait qui on est c'est ce que je
dis à mes parents de pas rentrer dans ce
jeu là parce que en fait on alimente on
alimente les haters en les repartageant
etc
malheureusement dans ce
violon
allait faire du jumeaux comme ça on
pourra se faire des bonnes vacances dans
un an on va faire le tour du monde
demain mais c'est vrai moi je joue avec
ça
en vérité c'est tellement bête de leur
part et stupide que je trouve ça fait
rire mais faut qu'à la raison c'est
c'est pas de les mettre en valeur parce
que moi je joue avec et il y en a qui
profitent qui se mettent en valeur mais
c'est plus fort que moi je suis pas
comme mes enfants et ma femme moi je
suis obligé de Gilles je suis obligé de
sortir aussi parfois se traduire à
l'encontre des enfants par à l'école des
problèmes etc vous êtes extrêmement
engagé contre le harcèlement scolaire
est-ce que certains de vos jeunes
enfants ont connu cette mésaventure à
l'école par rapport famille nombreuse
que les réseaux après déteignent à
l'école sur les enfants
alors nous on est une famille alors je
sais pas les autres familles je parle
pour ma famille on a jamais eu de
problème
on était déjà apprécié d'avant tout ce
qu'on faisait moi moi je suis un on
était un petit peu connu quand même le
fait parce qu'on était nombreux choses
mais sans faire la sans faire la famille
nombreuse on ne connaissait tous quand
même voilà on était quoi déjà parce que
voilà beaucoup d'enfants
de l'émission
la famille Blois j'ai même dépanner
faire la peinture chez eux j'ai
travaillé chez eux non non pas pénible
[Rires]
est-ce que vous pourriez le faire moi
oui non je rigole
moi peut-être que si j'aurais pas
d'enfant peut-être que je le ferai parce
que moi peut-être mais j'avoue mais non
même le regard des gens les amis la
famille alors je vous le dis euh
elle est pas du tout partante
pas du tout ah non j'ai horreur de ça
même par rapport à aux enfants tout ça
et ça ça reste même si t'as pas
d'enfants
asiatique
et tout le temps comme ça
c'est de l'humour vraiment
plus jamais on attend nos petits enfants
maintenant on se dit on achète on est
notre rôle maintenant c'est nos enfants
qui nous offrent leurs enfants après
parce qu'il faut savoir que c'est une
autre premier vrai voyage qu'on a fait
en 48 ans quand même donc j'avais fait
de voyage on a bougé mais du jour là 3
jours là c'est là c'est vraiment et ça
nous a vraiment tellement plus que
maintenant on a envie de profiter il y a
vraiment envie de bouger ouais on voit
vous êtes des parents très aimants et
c'est très agréable de vous voir tous
les photos est magnifique et alors
justement quand on est des parents
aimant comme vous qu'on a eu cette villa
avec tous vos enfants le temps passe
vous allez vous retrouver seul dans
quelques années on sera vieux déjà
justement comment vous appréhendez ça
ben déjà je pense que je me rattrape sur
mes petits-enfants je pense qu'on aura
nos petits-enfants déjà ah les petits
enfants voilà et puis sinon j'irai
chercher les gamins des voisins et puis
je sais pas j'en parlerai avec moi ou
j'adopte des gamins j'en prends deux
trois au hasard et puis non je rigole
c'est vrai que je pense ça va nous faire
peur parce que le fait des fois parce
que des fois même quand on se retrouve
tout seul dans un hôtel et tout je vous
jure vous me croyez pas on a un manque
on a un manque c'est comme ma fille
qu'en disait quand elle est partie
aménagée tout seul le fait du vide pas
de bruit je vous jure que on a vraiment
un manque est-ce que vous avez connu des
hauts et des bas dans le couple ok oui
bien sûr
[Rires]
non non c'est bon moi je suis parti un
peu de la maison parce que je faisais je
fais voilà je faisais des des petites
bêtises mais voilà ça me regarde moi
mais voilà mais bon
rien de ouf
non non mais autant que je les ai la
vérité façon ça se sait donc si tout le
monde
non mais ça c'est sûr donc
si je vous mens là et que demain vous
savez que femme formidable
comme on dit l'amour est plus fort que
tout mais bon après c'est vrai que
maintenant la confiance est plus comme
avant quoi je vais dire c'est ça qui
fait quoi voilà c'est bon
[Rires]
j'ai perdu j'accepte les règles donc
voilà on espère franchement vous avez
une chance
merci à vous je suis très conscient